one of the things that you did talk
about transformations is in this movie
you play yourself and not use your
character previously you play Gyllenhaal
Jake Gyllenhaal it's they take Joan
house story know if it was your a really
strange man you play that your character
you play your character at 22 and then I
think at 44 yes it there's a you play
both of those and as far as I could tell
they did no prosthetics or anything
other than when you're 22 you really do
look 22 and then when you're 44 you have
a beard and but it works am i right
that's pretty much what they did I mean
sort of yeah I mean I acted a little bit
yes you know okay what do you get when
you get to the end you're not gonna put
yourself on this show again tomorrow I'm
just gonna call up all right yeah I mean
I mean I guess that's sort of the gist I
mean yeah what I'm saying is you do you
are a terrific actor you do make it work
but it is prep out my beard when you're
watching the movie that you you totally
buy that that guy's 22 and that guy's 44
and they haven't done the thing they
usually do where they pour wax all over
someone and make them look you know what
I mean yeah I'm 44 you know Lori wax all
over somebody to make them older yeah
yeah no I mean like I I mean that that
is how by the way I perceive I would be
in a 44 is not that old like it's not
like that's how I behave when I was 44 I
once I cleared 40 I just immediately
started going like you kids don't know
what stop I do remember I do remember we
were doing a Brokeback Mountain I had a
scene where I was playing someone was
like 34 and I was much younger at the
time and I did a take and I was like
hobbling you know to the car and I
remember angry the director saying to me
you know you're not 75 years old
so I've learned since then you know and
I learned to just grow a beard grow up
yeah
and that's another no I mean it's it's
it Tom wrote an incredible screenplay
and I think this story kind of guides
you along in the way you go back and
forth between time and I think in that
you know you don't you know the
storytelling of the movie is so well
done that ultimately yes it's about
performance but I think we believe is an
audience when when the movie is really
good and the movie happens to be
excellent so yeah that's what you
believe the movie is absolutely stunning
let's take a quick break much more with
Jake Gyllenhaal stick around
[Applause]
you